one week from tonight it will be
election night right here in America and
the critical midterms you got it are
seven days away and we begin with good
news tonight for the GOP along with an
important warning to all voters across
the country that's coming but first the
good news in a shock to many Democrats
General Don Bolduc has now taken a
one-point lead over the incumbent Maggie
Hassan in New Hampshire's Senate race
this would be a huge Republican pickup
now General Bulldog by the way two
purple hearts five bronze Stars uh he
and Governor sununu will be on the show
together on Thursday night in the state
of Washington Republican Tiffany Smiley
is now in a dead heat it's an even race
with Patty Murray according to Trafalgar
and another poll that just broke moments
ago and in Michigan's governor's race
get this Tudor Dixon she will join us in
a moment she has now taken a lead over
Gretchen Whitmer out in Arizona Arizona
Carrie lake is a big Blake Masters is in
a statistical tie with Mark Kelly
however we have big news up from Arizona
tonight in what is a huge boost for
Blake Masters the third party
libertarian candidate just dropped out
of the race and he endorsed Blake
Masters for the Senate polls had the
libertarian candidate Mark Victor
polling at six points in other words
that's another six anti-markelli points
likely to go to Blake Masters or at
least a majority of them and that now
heavily favors Blake Masters for a
pickup with Republicans in Arizona
meanwhile we have more good news in
Pennsylvania Dr Oz is up following
fetterman's disastrous debate to form
performance but if you're in
Pennsylvania you need to be careful
Democrats are now dumping tens and tens
and tens of millions of dollars in one
smear ad after another on Dr Oz in this
last week of the campaign they are
desperate it to get that guy in the
hoodie the guy that never worked a day
in his life the trust fund brat that
once legalized heroin injection sites
paid for by taxpayers no restrictions on
abortion a moratorium on fracking wants
to release convicted murderers anyway
that race shouldn't be close but it is
so pay attention in Pennsylvania
Herschel Walker continues to outpole
radical Raphael Warnock in Georgia that
race also remains close and perhaps the
biggest political news comes out of the
deep deep blue state of New York where
Republican Lee zeldin is now officially
taking the lead in a brand new poll by
Trafalgar that's Robert kahali's group
now Lee zeldon will be here as he's
campaigning with Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis that's straight ahead and now
the numbers are really both of them will
join us now the numbers are really
encouraging but let me be clear and let
me pause right here these races are very
very close most of them are within two
points so make no mistake it doesn't
matter if your preferred candidate is in
the lead if your preferred candidate is
behind if your preferred candidate is in
a dead heat tie Anything Can Happen
don't think for a second this is a slam
dunk in other words every voter needs to
do their part take nothing for granted
and don't forget what is at stake here
you have a record 40-year high of
inflation which could have been
prevented and by the way you have the
highest gas prices and diesel prices
we've ever paid in our entire history we
have wide open borders almost four and a
half million illegal immigrants under
Joe Biden we have crime way up in small
towns and big cities all across the
country we have woke education versus
classical education winning out in way
too many cities and towns and by the way
all caused by the liberal Democrats and
the radical socialist agenda they
control the house they control the
Senate they control the White House they
spend spend trillions on this green new
energy their pet projects they have
stifled All American domestic production
of oil and gas the lightblood of our
economy they would rather beg countries
that hate our guts like Saudi Arabia
OPEC nations Venezuela Iran and Russia
then produce these things domestically
they have raised prices dramatically as
a result on everything you buy in every
store you go to they are the people that
kept your kids out of school and your
business is shut down they opened up our
borders like never before they release
violent felons from prison they
dismantle police departments and they
don't want their laws in many of these
cities and states they do not deserve
your vote and I'll take it a step
further they deserve to be fired one
week from tonight you have the power to
fire them I don't you do collectively we
do in fact with Democrats in charge the
suffering will only get worse and
needless to say democr cannot run on
their record instead Joe Biden you know
now in this last-ditch effort well let's
lie to senior citizens and scare them to
death with lies about Republicans they
want to take away your Social Security
and Medicare and cut it okay not a
single Republican has ever said it no
Republican supports it it's never going
to happen and this is desperation on
display take a look
senator from Florida
going after Medicare and Social Security
I tell you what I don't know where as
they say in southern doesn't know where
you all been God damn boy every year
every single year it should be in the
chopping block along with veterans
benefits and everything else in federal
budget
Congress doesn't vote affirmatively keep
it it goes away gone
you've been paying in Social Security
your whole life
you earned it
now these guys want to take it away who
in the hell do they think they are
excuse my language
who in the hell do you think you are
Joey lying to the American people that
is a lie Obama's been spreading the LIE
every democrat's been spreading the LIE
there's not a single Republican or
conservative that is advocating cutting
veterans benefits cutting Social
Security or cutting Medicare so Joe
appears to be malfunctioning yet again
and I'm sure by the way Marco Rubio and
Ronda Santos are shaking in their boots
because Joe is down in Florida because
that's probably the only place they want
to send them because they know they have
no chance of winning there now I think
there's a rocking chair by the way
somewhere in Delaware on the beach with
Joe Biden's name on it but if you think
that's bad just listen to his lies about
inflation transitory inflation inflation
is now almost over we have zero
inflation no we've had nothing but nine
straight months of of a 40-year record
high of inflation thanks to his energy
and economic policies take a look
and they talk about inflation
you know we're dealing with them for a
couple of SEC inflation is a worldwide
problem right now
because of a war in Iraq and the impact
on oil and what Russia is doing I mean
excuse me the war in in Ukraine
and uh think of Iraq because that's when
my son died
the uh because he died
wow war in Iraq none of that was true
Russia did not cause America's inflation
crisis and Biden's son did not die in
Iraq he has said it over and over again
it's not true it's no wonder that we you
know within a week we're going to go to
a pivotal election Democrats are once
again they are trying to hide the leader
of their party he is not mentally fit to
represent the party in any way as UVA
Professor leaning Democrat Larry sabado
stated quote to the extent that Biden is
less visible and maybe even invisible
it's a plus for Democrats out of sight
out of mind now that's why Joe is in
Florida Democrats election prospects
there are pretty much next to zero and
in Maryland where Democrats will
probably win every major race without a
contest and of course in contrast we
have former president Obama he is
pounding the campaign Trail very very
angry Obama out there in multiple key
states that actually matter yelling
screaming and lying at every single stop
he was in Georgia for a rally with oh
that's right he was there with his
fellow Jeremiah Wright lover and Louis
Farrakhan supporter Rafael Warnock
Warnock a big supporter of critical race
Theory a proponent of defund and
dismantle and no bail movement Warnock
also praising Fidel Castro that's the
trifecta Jeremiah Wright Louis Farrakhan
and Fidel Castro and he demanded by the
way that America repent for its
whiteness Obama then traveled to
Michigan where he praised on Governor
Whitmer for keeping kids out of school
for years and with some of the worst
lockdown rules in the country and the
former president also campaigned there
in Wisconsin for Mandela Barnes and
Barnes of course wants to cut the prison
population in half oh that's a brilliant
move he wants to end cash bail defund
the police and praise the 2020 riots 574
of them that Congress never investigated
but apparently that's all perfectly fine
with Barack Obama he supports all of it
next up is Nevada for Biden's rubber
stamp Christine Cortez masto then on to
Arizona for the Cowardly Katie Hobbs
perhaps well the worst candidate in the
country and finally to Pennsylvania for
the Socialist trust fund Brad who never
worked a day in his life in a hoodie
John fetterman now this guy is the
radical of all radicals lifelong
opponent of fracking he wants a
moratorium obsessed with letting
convicted first-degree murderers out of
prison wants to open up the prison
population and release at least a third
to half he wants Pennsylvania to be a
sanctuary State he wants you taxpayers
in Pennsylvania he wants your money to
fund safe heroin injection sites I'm
sure you're very happy about that at
some point soon Obama might also want to
take a special trip to New York and by
the way in Pennsylvania when Obama gets
there don't forget that he referred to
you as bitter Americans that cling to
your God Bibles guns and religion you
might want to come to New York also
Kathy hokel he's not doing particularly
well and we have much more on that race
coming up